"
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN MAKING SOME
BIZARRE COMMENTS ABOUT GUN
CONTROL.
AS HE SAYS HE DID NOT THINK THAT
WE NEEDED TO ARDENNES SCHOOLS,
ONE WEEK SINCE THE HORRIFIC
FENCE IN TEXAS WHERE A TEEN
GUNMAN WENT ON A RAMPAGE INSIDE
A CLASSROOM KILLING 19 STUDENTS
IN TWO TEACHERS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS OF THE
COUNTRY NEEDS TO ACT.
BUT SO FAR HE HAS NOT EVEN TALK
TO CONGRESS ABOUT SOLUTIONS.
AND DEMOCRATS SO FAR DO NOT SEEM
INTERESTED IN REPUBLICAN
PROPOSALS LIKE BOOSTING SCHOOL
SAFETY OR ADDRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH.
INSTEAD, BIDEN IS ATTACKING THE
MOST POPULAR HANDGUN FOR SELF
PROTECTION.
LISTEN.
SPEAK OF THE .22 CALIBER BULLETS
LODGED IN THE LUNGS, A
9-MILLIMETER BULLET BLOWS THE
LUNG OUT OF THE BODY, SO HIGH
CALIBER WEAPONS, THERE IS NO
RATIONAL PLACE FOR IT IN TERMS
OF SELF PROTECTION.
IT IS NOT IN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT NEVER ABSOLUTE.
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE
TRYING TO CLEAN UP WHAT HE MET
WHILE HE DOES NOT BELIEVE IN
HARDENING SCHOOLS.
>> HE SUPPORTS A BAN ON THE SALE
OF ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES AND
EXPANDED BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE DANGEROUS
HANDS.
HE DOES NOT SUPPORT A BAN ON THE
SALE OF ALL HANDGUNS TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, AND KNOW THERE
HAS BEEN CONVERSATION ABOUT
HARDENING SCHOOLS, THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING HE BELIEVES IN.
>> Jesse: AND VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS OFFERING UP ONE OF
HER SIGNATURE SALAD RESPONSES
WHILE CALLING FOR A ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN.
>> I WILL SAY AS I HAVE SAID
COUNTLESS TIMES, WE ARE NOT
SITTING AROUND WAITING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE SOLUTION LOOKS
LIKE.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR A
VACCINE.
WE KNOW IT WORKS ON THIS.
IT INCLUDES LESS ASSAULT
WEAPONS, AN ASSAULT WEAPON IS A
WEAPON OF WAR.
IT HAS NO PLACE --
NO PLACE IN A CIVIL SOCIETY.
>> Jesse: GREG, SO THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT SUPPORTING
HARDENING SCHOOLS AFTER YOU SAW
WHAT WE SAW LAST WEEK.
JUST OUT OF PURE TACTICAL
REASONS, BY GOING INTO A
NEGOTIATION WOULD YOU SAY, YES,
LET'S PUT IT ON THE TABLE?
SPEAK ALL I WILL EXPLAIN TO YOU
WHAT IS WRONG WITH HIS THINKING
ON THE ANSWER TO THIS.
IF YOU WANT A SOLUTION THAT YOU
CAN TRUST, THE PERSON THAT IS
VENTURING THE SOLUTION HAS TO
HAVE MORE THAN ONE VARIABLE OR
YOU DON'T TRUST THEM.
SO IF YOU HAVE --
IF YOU ARE A SINGLE VARIABLE
THINKER WHICH IS WHAT DEMOCRATS
ARE A ABOUT GUNS.
EVERYTHING THEY SAY WILL BE
GUNS.
THAT'S THE IDEOLOGICAL CAUSE.
NO ONE CAN TRUST HIM, BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR ANSWER IS
GOING TO BE.
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE GUNS,
GUNS, GUNS.
AND WE KNOW THAT MAYBE THAT
RIFLE, THE ACCESSIBILITY TO THE
RIFLE PLAYS A ROLE IN THE ROLE
OF THIS MASS SHOOTING, BECAUSE A
PERSON GOT A HOLD OF IT AND USED
IT.
ALL RIGHT, BUT YOU END UP IN
THIS IT IS SEE WHERE JOE BIDEN
FINDS HIMSELF WHERE HE IS
BANNING JUST COMMON HANDGUNS AND
DISMISSES HARDENING TARGETS,
WHICH ONLY MAKES SENSE IF YOU
ARE CLINGING TO ONE VARIABLE AND
KIND OF THIS FEEBLE BRAIN.
AND THIS IS WHY DON'T LOOK AT
GUN-CONTROL DIES, BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T TRUST THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUSHING THIS FORWARD.
THE SOLUTION SHOULD TACKLE THREE
VARIABLES.
IT SHOULD BE MORE THAN A GUN
CONTROL ISSUE.
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT SOCIAL MEDIA,
MENTAL HEALTH, HOW ARE SCHOOLS
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH?
AND THEN YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
GUNS.
I WILL BE TOTALLY INTERESTED IN
RAISING THE AGE TO 21 FOR THIS
RIFLE IF IT WAS DONE NOT AS A
WALL, BUT AS AN EXPERIMENT,
RIGHTS, SIX YEARS, TRY IT OUT,
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS SIX
YEARS.
IT'S HARD TO GET VARIABLES OUT
OF THIS, BECAUSE MASS SHOOTINGS
ARE NOT RARE ENOUGH, YOU CAN GO
FOR SIX YEARS WITHOUT ANY, BUT
THE POINT IS COMING YOU HAVE TO
TREAT IT NOT LIKE A LOG, BUT
LIKE TEST, IT REMOVES THE
SLIPPERY SOAP, WHAT IS NEXT?
THEN YOU CAN DO THE SAME THING
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA AGE MINIMUMS,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE REALLY
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT TOO AND
THEN YOU CAN LOOK AT BETTER
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOLS.
WHY ARE WE TESTING ALL OF THESE
THINGS?
IT'S BECAUSE WE GET STUCK IN A
SINGLE VARIABLE THINKING WHERE
YOU HAVE THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD SAYING ABSOLUTE GIBBERISH
BECAUSE HE CAN'T LEAVE HIS --
THIS IS A SINGLE IDEA PRISON.
HE CAN'T GET OUT OF IT.
>> Jesse: CAN'T GET OUT OF HIS
OWN PRISON.
JUDGE >> Greg: I HAVE BEEN
THERE.
>> Jesse: THEY ALL HAVE BAIL,
SO IT SHOULD BE EASY FOR HIM TO
WALK.
WHEN YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT SAY,
MAYBE WE CAN WORK WITH THE
REPUBLICANS AND THEN UTTERS OUT
TO THIS GIBBERISH ABOUT THE
BANNING OF 9-MILLIMETER
HANDGUNS, WHY WOULD YOU DEAL
WITH A GUY LIKE THIS?
SPEAK ON HIS HEAD I'M GOING TO
BE THE ADULT IN THE ROOM I MAKE
THIS WORK.
HE WANTS TO BUILD UP HIS
NUMBERS, HE GETS AN IDEA AND
GOES IN HIS CORNER, THIS IS WHAT
I AM GOING TO DO AND I DON'T
WANT TO DO ANYTHING ELSE, ALL OF
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO
WORK WITH ME.
DOES REMOVING GUNS LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF CRIME?
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO LOOK AT WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO WHICH JUST THIS PAST
WEEKEND THERE WERE NINE PEOPLE
KILLED AND I THINK THERE WAS
SOMETHING LIKE I DON'T KNOW, 40
SHOT IN CHICAGO.
GUNS ARE ILLEGAL IN CHICAGO.
SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME WE
ANALYZED THIS STUFF?
THE LAST TIME WE HAD A BAN ON
ASSAULT WEAPONS I REMEMBER I WAS
THE SITTING D.A. I WAS IN FAVOR
OF IT, AND THEN WE FOUND OUT
THAT THERE WAS NO DISCERNIBLE
CHANGE IN CRIME WHEN WE BAN
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
NOW LET'S LOOK AT CALIFORNIA,
CRIME IS GOING UP, SHOOTINGS
GOING UP, COMPTON, LOS ANGELES,
ANY OF THESE PLACES AND IT'S
WHERE YOU HAVE THE TOUGHEST GUN
LAWS IN THE COUNTRY.
SO THE VAST MAJORITY, AND PEOPLE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS, THE
CRIMES THAT ARE BEING COMMITTED
ARE BEING COMMITTED BY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ILLEGAL WEAPONS.
IN LESS THAN 2% OF ALL PRISONERS
HAD A FIREARM OBTAINED FROM A
RETAIL SOURCE AT THE TIME THEY
COMMITTED THEIR CRIME.
SO STOP WITH THIS BACKGROUND
CHECK AND ALL OF THAT, BUT IF
YOU WANT TO, LET'S COME TOGETHER
ON THAT.
WANT TO COME TOGETHER ON THAT?
MAYBE LET'S DO IT AND MAKE A
DEAL.
BUT THIS GUY IS TOO SIMPLE TO
MAKE A DEAL.
THE CONSTITUTION, THIS IS A
SECOND AMENDMENT, FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, FREEDOM OF RELIGION, AND
THIS GUY IS SO DITZY HE SAYS YOU
COULD NOT BUY A CANNONBALL WHEN
THEY PASS THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
HE IS SO LIMITED IN ITS
HISTORICAL REFERENCES, THERE IS
NOTHING THAT PREVENTED ANYONE
FROM BUYING A CANNONBALL WHEN
THEY WROTE THE CONSTITUTION.
AND MY LAST COMMENT IS THIS, THE
GUN RELATED DEATHS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ARE NOT ONLY MOST
OF THEM IN CITIES WHERE GUN
CRIMES ARE ILLEGAL, BUT THAT
THEY ARE ALSO IN CITIES WHERE WE
HAVE INDIVIDUAL WHO CAN GET
GUNS, WHO ARE PART OF GANGS AND
IN THE END HALF OF THE GUN
CRIMES ARE SUICIDE.
AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> Jesse: WHY WON'T HE PUT
MENTAL HEALTH ON THE TABLE?
JESSICA.
>> Jessica: MENTAL HEALTH IS A
CONVERSATION THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
NONSTOP.
AND IT'S REPUBLICANS --
>> Jesse: NOT ABOUT THIS.
>> Jessica: GREG ABBOTT DOES
NOT WANT TO MEDICAID EXPANSION
WHICH MAKES SURE THAT THE
POOREST PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES.
DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER NOT HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
THESE OTHER ISSUES.
THEY WILL ALSO TALK ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS OF WHAT HAPPENED.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT CHICAGO,
THAT'S A DIFFERENT BOX.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT CHICAGO.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS CARRIED OUT WITH
AR-15s.
400,000 AR-15s THAT ARE OWNED
BY AMERICANS BETWEEN 199094.
TODAY THERE ARE 20 MILLION.
DAN CRENSHAW WAS BEING
INTERVIEWED ABOUT WHETHER WE
HAVE A COMMON PROBLEM HERE.
3 MILLION PEOPLE AND 400 MILLION
GUNS.
IF THE FOUNDING FATHERS WERE
AROUND TODAY, DO YOU THINK THAT
THEY WOULD'VE SAID, WE DID THIS,
YES, SO THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE
MORE THAN ONE GUN?
PEOPLE CAN HAVE EIGHT GUNS, 15
GUNS, YOU DON'T, YOU DON'T SPEAK
TO THE FOUNDERS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY DO WE
THINK IT'S AN ABSOLUTE!
>> Jessica: 1994 WHEN WE HAD
THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN, WE HAD
THE KIND OF DATA COMING WANT TO
SAY PUTTING AN END, WE KNOW THAT
THE NUMBER OF MASS SHOOTINGS
WERE LOWERED BY 43% AND THEN IT
WAS ALLOWED BY GEORGE W. BUSH,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE AGAIN.
PEOPLE DO NOT NEED THIS SUPPORT
JUST WALKING AROUND.
IT IS UNNECESSARY AND KIDS ARE
DYING BECAUSE OF IT.
AND THERE ARE 19 COPS IN THE
HALLWAY.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE VALUABLE
THAN A GOOD GUY WITH A GUN,
THERE WERE 19 GOOD GUYS WITH
GUNS THAT STOOD IN THE HALLWAY
AND KIDS WERE STILL CALLING THE
POLICE.
>> Sandra: PEOPLE AT HOME ARE
GOING TO SAY GUNS DON'T KILL
PEOPLE, PEOPLE KILL PEOPLE.
HOLD ON.
WHAT ABOUT THE RED FLAG LAWS?
I FIND OUT THE MORE REPUBLICANS
I SPEAK TO, THERE IS MORE
OPENNESS IN SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY TO THE RED FLAG LAW.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BRINGING
BACK MORAL VALUES, WHICH MANY
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING IN THE
WAKE OF THIS, YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT GLACIAL CHANGE.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
COULD'VE PREVENTED A SHOOTING
LIKE THIS?
COULD RED FLAG LAWS HAVE HELPED?
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
IT'S AS GOOD AS THE DATA,
BASICALLY POINTING OUT THAT THIS
WAS A PERSON WHO BROADCAST OVER
PRIVATE MESSAGING ON FACEBOOK,
WHICH FACEBOOK HAS SAID THAT HE
WAS GOING TO GO KILL HIS
GRANDMOTHER AND THAT HE WAS
GOING TO GO SHOOT UP AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THAT DATA AT
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" POINTS
OUT IS ONLY PRIVATE TO THOSE HE
WANTED THAT PRIVATE FROM.
HOW ABOUT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS
INTERACTING THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION OVER SOCIAL MEDIA?
MAYBE THERE IS SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THESE RED FLAG LAWS
THAT COULD IDENTIFY AN UNSTEADY
PERSON THAT OWNS A GUN LEGALLY
OR ILLEGALLY.
>> Jessica: WE HAVE TRIED
THIS, DONALD TRUMP WHO WAS IN
NEW YORK WITH LIBERAL BEFORE HE
WAS A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT WAS
FOR GUN CONTROL.
AND IT WAS WITH THE RED FLAG
LAWS AND FELLOW REPUBLICANS TOLD
HIM IT WILL NOT PASS.
>> Jesse: THEY DID NOT WORK IN
BUFFALO.
>> Sandra: 19 STATES.
>> Jesse: DON'T TELL THEM A
GUN IF YOU HAVE A BAG OF DEAD
CATS, I THINK WE CAN AGREE ON
THAT.
>> Greg: WHERE DID THAT COME
FROM?
>> Judge Jeanine: HE WAS
HOLDING UP BAG OF DEAD CATS.
HE IS A PSYCHOPATH.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW HE CAN
AFFORD THOSE GUNS?
>> Jessica: BECAUSE THEY CAN.
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA WON'T
PURSUE THAT.
UP NEXT, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO CONVINC